bueno muchas gracias por la invitación
seguramente este
acontecimiento
que bueno ya era esperado por muchos por
la evidencia que se había venido sumando
en otros pues es nuestros juicios
incluso el hermano del presidente
hernández así como otros notificantes
efectivamente nos apunta a que la
infiltración de intereses criminales del
narcotráfico en honduras ha llegado en
los últimos años a tocar las más altas
esferas del estado y se ha enquistado de
una manera que estará de visita quizás
desincrustar por el gobierno entrante de
gestión maracas y otro problema en este
contexto es la operación del
narcotráfico internacional desde países
como venezuela y colombia eeuu cómo
funciona realmente este narcotráfico
bueno lo que no se lleva a este juicio
puede abrir contra la forma cuando
hernández y es que se extradita y el
juicio empieza este era precisamente
cómo funcionaba más que cómo funciona el
tráfico porque recordemos que los cargos
se refieren a como el presidente la ex
presidente e interactúa con estos grupos
para precisamente llegar a su cargo en
las elecciones pasadas en los
equilibrios son varían y es posible que
este proceso pues haga que es criminal
después de edad entonces se reconfiguren
en sus alianzas territoriales en frente
al nuevo escenario que está viviendo el
país y cambios en la puesta y seguridad
en el gobierno y en oxford
para terminar si resultara declarado
culpable de los cargos que futuro le
podría esperar al expresidente en eeuu
pues los cargos son muy serios y son
parecidos a los que enfrentó su hermano
tony hernández a cadena perpetua
más 30 años pero así que posiblemente se
está enfrentando a cargos que tengan una
condena muy larga
clemente de por vida vamos a ver cómo
nos enfrenta parece que su línea de
defensa sea mucho más
sólida y digamos preparada en la que fue
la del hermano precisamente pero habrá
que ver si la evidencia que logra
aportar a este a este proceso será
suficiente para efectivamente pues
desvirtuar las acusaciones de insultos
lo que es
particularmente es difícil de prever